hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
book ten of Aristotle's categories is
devoted entirely to discussing four main
types of what we translate as opposition
and you notice that I've got some Greek
terms up here on t case thigh is a verb
and antique aminah is the participle for
that verb meaning the things that that
that verb applies to and so I'm peaking
site means being opposed and we talk
about two things being opposed to each
other in a variety of ways and Aristotle
wants to clarify for us what the
antiquey men are the things that are
opposites or are opposed to each other
how they're actually connected with each
other because not every form of
opposition is for example being contrary
or being affirmatives and and negations
he wants us to be clear so that we can
tell when we're dealing with opposites
precisely what kind of opposites we have
in front of us because the different
sorts of opposites are related to each
other in different ways and so what what
applies to one of them may not follow
from what we know about another or apply
to another we want to be careful to
distinguish these so what are these four
types with correlatives we have
contraries we have privet ofthe and
positives and we have affirmative and
negatives and when you look at this list
and you think about the categories if
you've been reading through the work
we've already talked quite a bit by this
point about correlative as a matter of
fact there's an entire category that's
devoted to this the top roasty right the
the relation or relative so core
relatives are those things that fall
under relation then we have contraries
and we've talked about contraries quite
a bit for example substances don't have
contraries many qualities
are in fact contrary to other qualities
you know we can go on and on and those
are Ananta those are very important then
we have a fuller discussion of what we
can translate and it's a little bit
difficult to do this as primitives and
positives or another way of translating
this sometimes is privations and states
cirrhosis and hexes and then we have
opposition within language or within
thought when thought is being modeled
after language when we have affirmatives
and negatives cotta fascist canta
fascist is when you're saying something
of something you're declaring that or
you're stating that to be the case oppo
fascist the opposite of that you're
negating it you're saying that that's
not the case so let's talk very briefly
about each of these in kind in turn and
look at the examples that Aristotle
gives us double versus half for
correlatives this is one that he's used
already in the discussion of relation
remember too that this is not a quantity
term but a relation term core relatives
are of each other they have their
meaning in relation to something else so
double only really means something in
relation to what it is the double of
that is the half if we're talking about
pieces of chalk then we say that this
piece of chalk is double the length of
these two pieces of chalk we are
comparing them against each other you
can't just say this is double and then
leave it blank because that doesn't that
doesn't mean anything there has to be a
Co relative to which it is related and
and makes sense that we have contraries
and and we've given a lot of discussion
to these in other parts of the work and
we're going to give a bit more
discussion to these in this chapter as
well good and bad uses as classic
examples here
Agathon cock-on
we could talk about black and white he
also uses that if we're staying in the
realm of the senses the bitter and the
sweet aristotle tends to conceive of as
opposites to each other because he
places them along a spectrum then we get
to things like blindness and sight why
blindness in sight why aren't they
simply contours we're going to go into
some discussion of that as we move
through the work in another lecture
video suffice it to say here blindness
is a lack it is a stasis a taking away
and the absence a prime of the Faculty
of sight we could say you know same
thing about taste right those who lack a
sense of taste happened actually to to a
chef at one point who had cancer and we
had to work at recipes essentially from
from memory and based on his knowledge
of flavor profiles and how they interact
similar to Beethoven in in his period of
deafness having to understand music no
longer through the sense itself but in
the absence the privation of that sense
then we have affirmative the negatives
Aristotle gives as example he is sitting
he is not sitting notice what he doesn't
use for that he doesn't say he is
sitting he is standing because he is
standing would be another another kata
for another declaration or affirmation
just as something different we can do
this as well with you know this is
double this is half right this is not
double this is not half
this is good this is not good this is
bad this is not bad
so prefer motives and negatives can
apply in language and then you know
secondarily in thought to any of these
other types of opposition's but as
affirmations and denials or negations
they are something
from the rest of these so it's important
to keep in mind the distinction between
these four types of opposition they are
not all the same